you've got ideas on how investors can
actually play a potential I'm gonna say
it Eric's favorite term greg's it Greek
exit well you know it's interesting
there's there's a fundamental structure
to trades that are successful for hedge
funds and what we find in general you
know is that they have three sort of
characteristics they're consistent with
fundamentals there they have a variant
opinion you don't want to be with the
crowd and you want to have an asymmetric
return when we look at the setup of some
of the situations that you've got out
there right now a lot of them you know
the forward curve in the futures market
looking for a June July rate hike a lot
of that is in the market right now if
you look at the Fed first we look at
something like Italy though and the
Italian bond spreads Italy is actually
continuing to tighten Italian triple-b
banks are tightening versus Deutsche
Bank as we speak the notion that their
credit spreads have gotten better you're
seeing an element of market complacency
also interestingly even at the retail
level at the retail level Italian
deposits at banks by man-in-the-street
deposits at banks are up on the order of
eighteen percent since their peak the
Greeks have had the good sense to take
about a third of their money out of the
banking system which is extraordinary so
you've seen them hold on they're taking
their money out of the banking system
because they don't trust their own
system and if you don't if they trust
they if they do not trust their own
system isn't that another signal that
the grease is simply failing it
absolutely is but the thing is that the
hot money has left and when you're
setting up a trade getting in in front
of the hot money is your friend hold on
but isn't the hot money hedge fund money
so to say to be as successful to put on
a successful trade as a hedge fund
manager you have to have a variant
opinion they are the hot money they are
the ones crowding the trades exactly
right and that's why you don't want to
have that's why you don't want to be
necessarily in the Greek trade in the
Italian trade you've seen Italian
deposits go up by seventeen percent if
they get a whiff of a problem in the
Italian banking system there's going to
be a run of tremendous magnitude on the
Italian banking system but that doesn't
seem to be the case now
beneteau being a perfecto and here
you've got something which maybe he's
got a ten percent chance of occurring
but with a massive pay off right now
spreads around a hundred and twenty four
they've gone out to 550 in the last ones
the Greeks EDS is one-tenth of what it
was before the Italians and we're at
raise is in one of notes as well as
where it trades it's it's literally
trading for one-tenth the world would
seem like investors aren't paying
attention to what's really happening in
Greece because back in two thousand
twelve greets EDS blew out exactly and i
think you know look the balance of
probability is that they will kick the
can down the road but what you want to
look at is yes you've got a ninety
percent chance of that not happening and
it might cost you a dollar but if you
can put on a trade that if it does
happen and something goes wrong and you
see you know the Greek speaking in that
language and Merkel says you know what
your eight million people go pound sand
I'm not gonna set a bad example for the
Spanish and the Italians and they do let
them go you're gonna have a huge payout
ratio and that's I think what the hedge
fund managers are looking for a
symmetric pay off and that's there in
the Italian spreads what's the hedge
fund vibe right now what do you think
january look like we know ray dalio had
a good month but a lot of hedge funds
got hit the wrong way on the Swiss franc
move you not that many would have had
that carry on it I don't think that they
saw it going quite as far as it is in
general with it what what you're seeing
the hedge funds loving Brazil you know
with the changes there with the spread
widening out and tremendous positive
carry you do see a fair amount of
investors long Brazil you also see some
people still playing the fed tightening
above all else it's a long dollar play
every single one of them comes down as a
function of do you wanna be long dollars
versus oil-producing currencies long you
know short Canada and energy currencies
you also starting to see people looking
at fixed currencies if there is a hiccup
the pressure is the people who have set
currencies this goes way back to the
sterling deutsche mark trade of old but
the currencies that have been locked in
particularly some of the currencies in
the Gulf are going to come under
pressure where people are trying to find
as a way to get short the venezuelan
bolivar that is the great white whale of
hedge fund trades if you can find a way
to do it people love that trade